There are so many video
streaming services right now,
Netflix, Disney+, HBO Max, NBCUniversal,
blah, blah, blah.
They just launched the
Peacock streaming service.
You'd think that's more
than enough, right?
You'd think that would be all you'd need,
like we're all done.
But guess what?
If you did guess that, you'd be wrong,
because yet another new
video streaming service
launched just today.
That's right.
Take a look.
[Andy] In the past four months,
Zoom has become a way of life.
And now, that trend continues
with the latest video streaming
service, Zoom to the Max.
Thanks to our policy
of secretly recording every
Zoom meeting ever held,
Zoom to the Max can now
offer you a streaming library
of literally millions of videos,
including such classics as the
co-workers who stay on Zoom
after a meeting to trash everyone else.
You guys see that his virtual background
was his daughter's
Princeton acceptance letter?
Oh.
What a (bleep) tool.
[Raymond] I'm still here.
Yeah, we knew that.
[Andy] Obligatory chats with your parents.
I mean, her father wasn't
in the best of health.
He was pretty obese.
I don't know what the family
was eating, but whatever.
She was pretty chunky-looking, too,
the other day when I saw her.
[Andy] Getting on a Zoom
meeting on the wrong day.
Hey.
Guys?
[Andy] The best of poorly-lit meetings.
And you know that each of you belongs
to a different team.
[Andy] Zoom bloopers.
So we'd probably be better off going
with a motherboard that has an integrated
10 gigabit ethernet connection.
That way, hey!
(screaming)
(crashing)
[Andy] Zoom Tinder dates.
Ah.
Oh my god.
(dog growling)
Ah.
Oh!
Yeah.
(dog growling)
[Andy] Zoom Bloopers, Volume 2.
Just for our third quarter goals,
if we could make sure that-
(crashing)
(screaming)
[Andy] And Volume 3.
So we don't have to worry about wasting
a lot of time rebuilding volumes
in the event of a-
(shouting)
Oh.
I'm okay.
[Andy] Zoom to the Max,
because Quibi lowered the bar.
(upbeat music)